okay so there has been a lot of internet
chatter about high on life and most of
it is about the writing and the humor
and and people liking or disliking it
which i obviously think is totally fair
you can not like
humor in games i think it's very hard to
get right because so much of humor is
based on timing and in a video game
players control timing so it can be very
very difficult to deliver a punch line
how do you even make sure that they're
looking the right way for the punch line
to be delivered it's a different
challenge to uh film and tv for sure but
i also feel like some of the
commentaries been a little bit weird
like if you don't like it why would you
why would you just not play it that said
i don't know where i land on the human
yet i'm not sure if i'll like it or
dislike it
i know that the team did publicly say
that there isn't constant talking there
is an earlier levels for tutorialization
purposes but that it tones down but the
thing that they've done that i think is
very very cool
is they've effectively made weapons your
companions and there is dynamic dialogue
so that the weapon slash companion um
you know they're they're no different to
a skyrim fallout
used to bethesda example bethesda style
companions would operate
except that they're also
actually a gun rather than somebody who
shoots by your side um but yeah they
also instantaneously
uh comment on the things that you're
doing which is cool and very difficult
it's hard to do requires a lot of voice
lines so
i'm very impressed by that so this is uh
25 minutes of hopefully unedited
gameplay that we're going to jump into
and just see how they expand on that
right here let me
make my screen smaller
and we have audio we have audio
there we go
now we have audio
i also like don't know if i love the
gameplay yet some of it seems
interesting
interested to watch this because it's
like still assessing if i'm excited for
this game or not rundle concert we have
with us today
nice house you got here real ritzy way
better than my bench oh wow you really
made yourself at home huh oh there you
are who's this weirdo and why is he
setting up a [ __ ] huge alien computer
in our living room okay
first of all that alien computer nice
house is a very expensive and
surprisingly operational bounty five
thousand so uh are you welcome what five
thousand your kid here thinks they're
gonna be a big bad bounty hunter i set
them up with some fancy equipment so
they're letting me have the house doing
this instead of a cut scene i wonder if
you can leave kid i'm their sister how
old do you think i am
i don't know what kind of alien you are
yeah i wonder if it locks you in this
room so that you have to
that's what you did look i know it's a
lot all at once but we need him to save
your species so do you think you could
put up with him for a bit well yeah if
it's going to help sure i'm sorry
everything i've ever known just got
flipped upside down so i don't know
what's weird or not anymore hey
i don't like getting it's an alien
invasion so i'm just going to actually
know the couch later i don't have to
[ __ ] right now but just a heads up like
that was that weird or was that normal
it was weird right it was weird i mean i
really i can't tell i think i i need a
minute to slow down and process
everything
also i'm still tripping your mom's nice
anyway come talk to me when you're ready
to get down to business so you just play
as like a kid
i'm home
oh oh wonderful you're home
i've been i look at the dinner's cold i
prepared for us where were you i was
just doing smuffle guffins
you know it's so justin roiland
but of course it is and i also saw
complaints about that where someone was
like
oh it's just the same humor as every tv
show um and other people have said that
much more politely i did uh respond to
someone
making uh the criticism that it's too
rick and morty and it is very rick and
morty but uh in my head you know squanch
games is obviously an extension of
justin riley who does a lot of improv
that's just like a style and i don't
think that there is a lot of that in
video games um if you're gonna complain
about stuff that's cookie cutter you'd
complain about the open world ubisoft
formula uh i don't think that there is a
saturation of
the squash game style in games um and
it's also just like if you didn't like
rick and morty i doubt that you would
like this game you'd probably not be
into it and that is okay
it's okay to not like
games old planes don't thought about him
to the ground you knew this i don't
think i could stay married to somebody
who just blatantly does smuffle guffins
well i don't so what we just jump into
the deep end and start hunting down g3
officers or what
i'm not sure you're ready just yet i
mean they don't let you [ __ ] the
glumpers at glumpies without a level
four [ __ ] pass do they uh what i i don't
know well they don't maybe i should send
you out on a little test run first huh
uh okay sure i've got just the thing a
small time local gangster by the name of
nine torg she took my favorite knife
she's got an operation out in the slums
maybe a killer and get my knife back
then we'll talk maybe take you out to
glumpies to celebrate all right so we we
just head out to the slums no [ __ ] you
gotta use the bounty 5000 to initiate a
bounty that's what i went through all
the trouble of setting it up for so i
think it probably does
keep you in the room a la half style i'd
be curious if this game has cut scenes
um or where or how many
yeah [ __ ] not only that thing will warp
you close to the bounty but uh i guess
it ain't working so what do we do calm
down the bounty's right here in blim you
mind just heading out on foot the slums
gateway ain't too far from here i'll get
the bounty 5000 all fixed up while
you're gone yeah sure all right let's go
bounty hunter revealed ancient secrets
revealed their secrets and they're
ancient and we're gonna reveal them just
just watch oh man
don't get confused because i want
science kid go head out to this that's
the cinematic to the slums kill nine
talk and get don't forget it's a very
mini one oh it looks kind of like the
cylinder
the slums i guess look it shouldn't be
too far listen just follow the waypoint
that's why you're wearing that fancy
suit isn't it i mean it's got the
augmented reality thing on it right
it's a
fun way to tutorialize for
sure looks a lot like that like little
downtown area inside
like a ton
[Music]
and the mandatory sexual repression
chips that we put in our elderly
citizens have once again backfired
it's not a very interesting open world
though
just aesthetically the colors and stuff
are cyberpunky but
pretty empty
though maybe it's actually not an open
while this could still be a linear part
for all i really know
[Music]
nice one ign
you are going the wrong way
uh
[Music]
that's funny that's very funny
you just learned how the whiteboard
system works hey don't even think about
going down to the slot yeah this is a
maintenance only chef subscribe okay
that's gotta be the way into the slums
here let me sweet talk these two um
weirdos
hey uh kit uh excuse me can we get our
uh uh we need to make our way into the
slumps please no hold on so you really
wanna get into the slums huh then [ __ ] a
little bit further come on come on don't
don't make him answer this man i want to
know it's fine we'll we'll help okay
great
if you saw us at the bar
which of us would you ask out
uh the red one oh okay exactly that's
what i figured you'd say yeah everyone
always says him hey don't feel bad man
you're still plenty hot i'm just hotter
blue's a hotter color that's that's
science i know i know i know i just i
just wish one time someone would say i'm
hotter you know i put so much work in i
watched all those skincare tutorials and
i got surgery so if the poop anymore
that's your problem it should be
effortless
everyone can sense all that desperation
all the sadness is just radiating from
you but me
i'm just true blue all natural hot baby
it's true am i just really a lost cause
be honest
i like them a lot but i wonder yeah you
can't match up to the blue
like you have to do guys
pretty fragile you know don't worry
about him he's weak and disgusting he
doesn't get what it's like for us i like
the way they're animated sorry for
making you talk to him can i uh make it
up to you by letting you use my door
anytime you want free passage in and out
of the slump well really that that would
be amazing actually i also wonder how
many ways in there
because mine's shut forever for you yeah
so what do you think now huh you still
think i'm ugly oh yeah i'm ugly but i
have a door you can't use oh sorry
really but i guess it's fine you can use
just use the other door
i don't know i think it's entertaining
as best we could you know
i've never been topside oh lord
i wonder if there's any looting oh
it's a top cider not interested
hey oh my god i broke my [ __ ] leg
coming down that pipe be careful sorry
to hear that
well well
look what we got here fresh meat hey
there fresh meat welcome to the slums
fresh meat
oh boy here we go [ __ ] kid what's
wrong fresh meat you scared of a little
kid you have a little kid look at me
look at me
this
i am not shooting a kid go ahead do it
shoot me fresh me shoot me oh you shot
me i'm dead eh all right there i don't
love that well i didn't think we'd be
allowed to kill him normally killing
children in games isn't isn't allowed
but he's dead we killed this kid are you
happy now we killed a kid a kid is dead
now there goes our e for everybody
rating
again i would it's a bit much but i do
like the e for everybody
you gotta take
[Music]
nice yeah good pan
good pan ign nice nice nice
it's a cool world
kind of a final fantasy vibes even
seven that is
so it finally happened someone killed my
son your son yep the kid up there who
always calls everyone fresh meat we are
so sorry listen don't get used to that
we're not killing any more kids i'm
drawing the line so savor it enjoy it it
happened tuck it away in the old memory
book no it's fine he was 30 years old so
don't feel too bad 30 years old is still
adolescents for our species but it's not
as bad as shooting like a five-year-old
or something so don't worry you just did
regular murder and i warned him over and
over i said don't sit up there calling
strangers fresh meat or some gun-toting
psychopath is gonna shoot you dead in
cold blood and you went and did it good
for you anyway please just leave me to
mourn jesus
hey you can't pass through here it's
night towards term jesus enough there's
a lot of interaction
but it is all scripted it seems like
foot soldiers
the people lying on them
sidelines don't interact
[Music]
gemini flashbacks to be honest
wow all right
we got them all
usually these tours aren't so hostile
something must be going on let's look
around for somebody who can help us so
you you think maybe there's somebody
friendly around here who can help i mean
maybe try using your scanner uh you know
when you're on your on your suit like
sorry i don't mean to be a backseat
driver i'm just sharing my ideas
i'm like half off on the humor it is
making me laugh um i got all this some
of it i'm like we should just cut one
line back just kind of we're fishing
away waiting for someone to come home
i'm just gonna whistle hello there
friend can i help you
do you know how we can get to ninetorg
buddy all i know is fish and i barely
know fish but let's just pretend there's
a laundromat you can sneak through to
get to sledge works over there are we
pretending or is there really a
laundromat come on kid take the hint
either we're pretending or nine torx
goons kill me for squealing okay i got
it we're pretending oh christ just
follow that path along the sludge
so how do you like living down here in
the slums it's sort of colorful down
here at least what are you serious this
is one of the worst places anyone can
live you can't see that just by looking
at it it's more sludge than anything
else and the sludge is toxic
oof sorry yeah that sludge does look
pretty awful no the sludge is the best
part it's the quickest way out just hop
in there and you got a one-way ticket
out of here damn imagine if we didn't
have the sludge then we'd really be
trapped anyway yeah living here is bad
hey thanks for the info uh wise
fisherman we'll see you later i really
like the way the gun is animated
hey you want to see a cool party trick i
used to do amy at those spinny platforms
come on come on give it a shot it'll be
fun
oh yeah i told you did you see how fun
that was i call it my glob shot it comes
out of my trick hole all gatlings have a
different kind of trick hole mine does
this boy you are learning a lot today
aren't you
nice try
bol messenger
[Music]
yes yes oh
god i can't do this all day doesn't this
[ __ ] rule god i love spewing big
gloopy globs
[Music]
oh boy
watching somebody
try and do something and mess it up in a
demo is is tough it sucks it they can't
re-record it but i guess it's
it's what the experience probably would
be
most of the time you have commentary i
got an idea it's another trick up my
little slimy sleeve try hitting him with
my glob shot take your time and aim
right
you're gonna whoa perfect shot you
[ __ ] nailed it how sick was that
okay i gotta recharge it doesn't take
too long but it's a little longer when
there's enemies nearby you know my my
body gets too tense it's like trying to
piss when someone's watching you know
i do really like that way of
tutorializing
go nuts use my glove shot and then just
shoot them in the air and juggle them
and you know it's gonna look sick
that's it like clearly they tried to use
it again by hitting i'll be and they
couldn't
so it triggered it re-explaining
looks like he was die clean only
all right this has to be the way to nine
torque let's keep moving hey careful
with the merchant oh hold up a bit get
them first line up and everything
they're gonna be here any minute just
just patient oh [ __ ] you i'm sick of
this what's tonight
through someone's guts oh i think
they're talking about gene's night [ __ ]
you got it freak we've had enough of
your [ __ ] who's the best who are you
uh hey hello there friends oh i think
it's the buyer hey are you the buyer
no i'm just here to do my laundry it's
even clean i just i'm a laundry head
can't stop washing stuff over here this
room's off limits everything you need is
in the front get out of here good luck
with your laundry i really thought that
was gonna be the buyer we don't know
what they sound like so we have no way
of knowing if it was them or not okay
i'll just say it that plan was dumb i'm
willing to accept some of the blame but
don't do any more dumb stuff can we try
it again and do it right this time
okay this must be the buyer hey buddy
are you the buyer
i'm
sorry to disappoint i am i'm not i'm not
the buyer i guess then get out of here
quit wasting our time okay so i don't
know if we're playing hard to get or
what but honestly it was really obvious
we were supposed to say we were the
buyer but listen all right you know you
did your best let's let's just try again
okay
okay this must be the buyer hey buddy i
think this is cute
uh yeah we're here to uh buy buy a knife
you guys are selling a knife yeah oh
perfect you're really late we were
starting to get worried just go with it
no shooting
all right here's the product a genuine
talking knife i gotta be honest with you
he's a real piece of [ __ ] he's extremely
violent he basically only talks about
wanting to kill people in very
disturbing ways [ __ ] you i'm gonna carve
out your anal cavity gonna make it three
times as big your shit's just gonna drop
right out of there let's see what i'm
talking about [ __ ] yes thank you pleased
to meet you i'm knifey now use me use me
let me [ __ ] stop this [ __ ]
oh [ __ ] yes oh
my god you know how sympathy that got
for me okay listen point me at your raw
fleshy little tummy and jab me right
into there let's get all those guts torn
up let's see that [ __ ] red goop spill
out i am going to find this knife very
uncomfortable the knife gene was talking
about
did you just say gene okay change of
plans bring me to jane something about
stabbing even in video games
what why he sent us to rescue you oh
that's rich there's no way i'm forgiving
him though for leaving me with that
[ __ ] nine talk he's dead to me huh
you know ninetorg we're trying to kill
her oh perfect finally we're on the same
page let's kill nine taug then gene okay
definitely nine torque but let's put a
pin in the the whole gene thing how do
we get out of here with my tether
ability i'm more than just a knife
you're racist i can tether too look up
and latch on
here here we go [ __ ] cool right
[ __ ] yeah not as good as stabbing but
still pretty good well all right where
to next the sludge so i think this is
bad nine talk was talking about some
trader she had to deal with dialogue
appeared in a different trailer
whatever i don't know
again just the tutorial
who the [ __ ] cares stop thinking so hard
and just look for the big sludge work
sign i want to stab somebody
i do not like the knife not a fan of the
knife to the extent that i feel like i
just like probably wouldn't even use it
but that's okay that's like companions
you don't like you know that's it it
really is just an awesome piece of
packaging
they just happen to like be in your
hands you mentioned that gene gave you
tonight
oh hey there's some gather roll that
that that'll fill me back up whoa thank
jesus okay feed me that gather all baby
come on put it in my little mouth what
is it do you not see the cat
oh
take me to mama mommy uh that's the
stuff
that's cool
not quite uh
an offender
yeah i don't know how to combat like how
fun it's gonna be it's really kind of
hard to say
because it's such a specific style
it's almost hard to assess without
playing it
i really like to give it a try
i guess that's a good thing this is a
game poss game i believe so oh man i
guess i am at this point let's ride this
wave and kill her i think this game is
really interesting obviously very unique
but i actually don't know if it would be
like a game
um pay 60 per day one
and that's thankful for gay pulse means
i get to check it out
see if i eventually want to finish it
i'm not sure what came over me there i
think i got caught up in the moment or
something but hey good work team let's
go get nine torque any last words spot
towards that nine toward talking
i've always said you were the worst torg
you know seven torx said the same thing
right before i killed her i recognized
that voice i thought
died in her sleep oh yes she did she
fell asleep on top of 30 bullets that i
shot right into her skull
and you're next
you got this
[Music]
all right
i think this is the fight that
we already saw
from the actual
stay in the air
the verticality i'm always
don't care about the guns something
about knife
[Music]
get him out of speed
and i guess like
right now it feels like it's lacking an
arsenal
when you have more guns
you've got the knife but this person is
not using it at all
i would like to see what the deflect
looks like but um
yeah the player is just not
even trying to use it
on the inside
yeah i think probably when we get more
more weapons things
[Music]
soldiers are extremely strong honestly
see i like that those clips are cute
i wonder how long this game is
how much dialogue they actually have
come
on i want to see what it looks like
i think it's like left stick
if i'm going out i'm taking you with me
whoa cool
would have loved to seem to deflect ign
that's all i'm saying
[Music]
oh okay god i can't look i can't i can't
buy pretty quick like i definitely
obviously still want to try this for
myself see how i feel about it
the humor i think is gonna be good
actually um i feel positively about it
uh i feel like it's a lot at the
beginning again because of that
tutorialization but even in the segments
where there's less of it i don't know i
like it it could obviously be too much
um and it is obviously very personal
preference
but still very interested in the weapons
i think some of the stuff i'm not as
into is just like the way the world
looks probably the way some of the
scenarios look um it looks pretty
um
[Music]
hallway
shooty arena hallway shooty arena type
style which is something that i just
think uh
we've evolved beyond in a lot of ways um
but yeah i'm surprised that this game is
gathering so much attention uh
it's very interesting
and i think i'm into it but it's
definitely gonna be a thing that i will
try on game pass i'm sure i'll do the
first hour gameplay video when it comes
up and
see how i end up feeling